in an affluent part of one of the
world's richest cities a sense of how
even before this new world the wealth
was shared so badly all of this has been
donated by people whose children no
longer need it
for those so poor they can't afford it
themselves before the virus expects
until new mothers from the poorest
demographic would come here to be told
that things would be okay but now they
can't and the worry is that if they're
at home they're stranded families were
already struggling with a broken system
before this all started and what we're
seeing now is families struggling to get
hold of the stuff that they need
struggling with incomes that are falling
when they don't have a safety they don't
have a safety net they don't have
savings but also just the social and
emotional impact of being at home often
with small children often in quite
cramped spaces the human cost of all
those two closed shops is just becoming
understood many businesses can and have
now applied for the government to pay
their staff but just as happened in
Spain in Italy a few weeks ago well over
a million people have suddenly now
applied for government benefits in one
of the world's most expensive cities you
could be from any social demographic
with a baby due about now and be in a
load of trouble it's already the case
that nearly a third of children in the
UK live in some form of poverty and the
expectation is that perhaps a fifth of
all adults in this country will be
forced to claim benefits through losing
their jobs because of the virus that in
turn means that even in traditionally
middle-class areas like this people are
facing the prospects of bringing their
children up on benefits Viki used to
receive support from the little village
charity when she was expecting now she
has to get by on benefits she lives in a
single room in a house with her daughter
who's now two and a half the virus means
they're stuck in here together for most
of the day it's tough it's expensive and
it's endless you know other things go up
not just your rent but your phone bill
cost of deliveries for packages that you
need because it's not always essentials
you need you need other things to keep
your kids busy as well
the UK government program known as
universal credit was already
controversial as the money takes weeks
to arrive and forces people to choose
between things like rents and food some
big players in the charity world are now
demanding the authorities go further to
protect those most at risk they've got
lots of extra costs with food with extra
energy particularly with internet and to
be able to support their children's
learning at home and they just need that
bit of extra support to be able to cover
those costs and to be able to make ends
meet a little village charity now
describes itself as virtual changing its
model to deliver goods to the most
desperate rather than hosting them but
they admit they're having to push hard
to meet the fast-growing demands the
realization is dawning that just as
those born after the banking collapse
more than a decade ago grew up in
austerity so those born now are going to
be raised by parents with no idea when
their work might come back and
potentially with years of hardships who
follow them lawrence lee al jazeera in
london